[Music]
good morning and welcome also to our
live streaming audience it may not be
very early where you are so thank you my
name is Paul I'm a product manager on
Chrome and I'm Dominic a software
engineer on Chrome we're here from
Sydney Australia today are there any
Australians in the room ah terrible why
aren't we all all here in in person well
but before we get started let's do a bit
of a show of hands how many of you here
have heard of progressive web apps Oh
almost everyone fantastic and how many
of you have actually built a progressive
web app well fantastic
getting to half I think great so for
those of you familiar with progressive
web apps already we're gonna show you
some of the things we're really excited
about both what's happening now but also
what's coming down the pipe in the
roadmap if you're new and you're
thinking what's all this fuss we'll try
to explain we talk a lot about how the
web is universal and that could mean a
lot of things but what we mean today is
that anyone can publish and anyone can
access content on the web you don't need
to be well-known or wealthy and it
doesn't matter what device is your
end-users are using and this was true in
the beginning when websites were basic
static and images and text but what's
really interesting is that it's remained
true today even as we have expanded the
capabilities of the web to do things
like rich media streaming interactive
graphics and really full web apps you
can still more or less create at once
and your users can consume it anywhere
on any device they happen to have this
is really important as devices have
really proliferated and exploded so as a
developer today you don't really have to
think about the number of people ESA's
and devices and all the different
details that happen when your website
goes out and people consume it anybody
can really access it you've got hundreds
of vendors
hundreds of form factors all sorts of
different geographies and industry niche
it just works
but there's one area where this really
isn't true today and that's applications
if you're building an application you
still have to think about which platform
it's going to be used on and you have to
develop it once for every major platform
so one of our big questions here was why
should this universality only work for
websites why can't we bring this
functionality to applications so that as
a developer you can make your
application once and have it run on all
these different devices so what all the
fuss is about is we'll talk today about
how that's really starting to happen and
we're really excited about that but
before we can really talk about
applications we need to we need to look
at what that word means
and we get this question a lot people
come up to us like great progressive web
apps so what's an app and everybody has
their own angle on it so just to sort of
put a stake in the ground will tell you
what we look at as an application so we
take a step back and look at the web the
web does a lot of application like
things Gmail and maps brought rich web
apps more than ten years ago
and fifteen years ago and ever since
then the valley and unicorns around the
world have really leveraged this to
build build their businesses rich web
applications amazon.com Facebook all
these things so today it's a huge part
of the tech industry but they still
don't feel like an application they
don't feel like a Photoshop or a word so
why is that if we put apps up next to
what we sat on the web they stand apart
in a number of ways you can launch them
from an icon on your desktop you can
launch them when you double-click the
right kind of file when you launch them
they open in their own window and that
window has a consistent UI that really
makes it feel like one person designed
it it can start up offline sometimes
they don't do much after they start up
but they can always start up and they
can take advantage of all of the cool
tech in the latest devices fingerprint
readers and new accelerometers and all
that stuff so when we look at
applications
these are the kinds of characteristics
that we think matter and our goal is to
bring those capabilities to the web
directly using pwace we want to break
the web out of the browser so that it
can deliver this app-like behavior we're
not really alone in trying to crack this
problem if you look at technology
architectures like electron like Cordova
like react native this is a common kind
of desire how can I use this web
technology to build native apps PW
always take this idea just one step
further and actually build this directly
on the web we want to bring users the
best of both worlds
and we want to make it so that you spend
less of your time but sing with
different platforms and more of your
time and effort on making your users
happy so how's that working out so far
DOM is gonna bring us up to speed thanks
Paul let me take you back a few years to
the start of our journey with PW A's on
Android in 2015 in a mobile first world
the mobile web was in a particularly bad
way and users had clearly shown that
apps were their preferred medium on an
increasingly preferred device three key
properties really stood out about apps
on mobile firstly they often had a
faster peer oh you I that was built with
the device and touch interaction model
in mind next on devices where typing was
difficult having a homescreen launcher
icon for instant easy access was a
paramount importance and finally deep
system integration having the app show
up in places like share sheets app lists
and settings was necessary to make an
app feel well like an app
those last two in particular are two of
those superpowers that we just
highlighted so we leant on progressive
web apps as a vehicle to level the
playing field for the mobile web we
focused on encouraging developers like
yourselves to build touchable mobile
first responsive experiences to address
the UI gap
we went to work fixing the system
integration ensuring that installed
pwace interacted seamlessly with Android
and other apps we worked on lots of the
little details making sure that the app
launched properly from push
notifications or from web links from
other apps since then our core goal has
been to use PWS to allow you to build an
experience that's indistinguishable from
native we've definitely got a lot of
areas to improve on but our work has
really paid off in adoption user
engagement and developer success fast
forward to today all major mobile
browsers support PWA installation even
iOS now will focus mostly on desktop for
the rest of this talk but if you want to
hear more about the latest on pwace on
Android you should check out the talk at
12:30 on stage eight taking chrome
fullscreen with trusted web activities
back to the history while Mobile is now
a dominant of consumption platform
desktop remains the dominant creative
platform we knew that transforming that
success on mobile to success on desktop
would require significant additional
investment well we made that investment
and we're excited to announce that as of
March this year we now support
installing progressive web apps and
running them as standalone app
experiences on all Chrome platforms
Chrome OS was the first desktop platform
to get support in early 2018 we took the
time to reimagine the UX for desktop
settling on a themed title bar a 3.9 you
to access useful browser functionality
and the title bar serves as a security
surface for us where we can disclose
things like permission usage and anchor
prompts for features like autofill and
translate
we followed Chrome OS with Windows and
Linux support in late 2018 for both of
those we retained the title bar design
with the window controls matching the
style of the host OS with Linux showing
the app icon in the title bar and Mac
support was shipped in March this year
with the familiar left-aligned traffic
light window controls and centered app
title now it's possible to do things
like this
here you see Sketchup web a 3d modeling
tool running as an installed PWA and
looking native on all three desktop
platforms one code base we're really
excited about the possibilities that
this opens up for all of you the web is
no longer confined to the browser but
open as an app platform where you can
make native experiences available right
once run anywhere let's make this a bit
more real I'm gonna walk through an
introduction to the key ingredients of
progressive web apps for many of you
who've built them before this is going
to be familiar and for those of you who
are new to pwace it'll hopefully give
you a great starting place to build on
but if you take nothing else away from
this talk just take this PWA s
are just websites with a few additional
pieces being websites they should work
perfectly well in the browser any
browser and being the web these
additional pieces also work in the
browser users should never have to
install a pedo
in order to use its capabilities but
taken together these additional pieces
are the progressive in progressive web
apps the ability to be installed to
function while offline and to access the
api's and operating system integrations
that create a compelling app experience
even better these pieces all the code
that I'm about to show you works on
mobile and desktop the look and feel is
tailored to the platform but it's the
exact same code cross platform and cross
browser and that's really the power of
the web why we do what we do we might
take a little longer on the web platform
to deliver capabilities and integrations
but when we do it it's done universally
so let's start with the first puzzle
piece the web app manifest this is a
JSON file linked from your pages header
element it provides application metadata
that's used for a variety of purposes
note that we usually expect the manifest
to be retrievable without needing to
attach credentials to the request if
that's not the case for you you'll want
to add the cross origin attribute to
your manifest declaration and that will
cause the browser to make a credential
request for the manifest that attaches
things like cookies here's an example
manifest that our team built for
squooshed app it's an image compression
PWA that lets you access all of the
advanced options offered by native image
compressors but right in the browser
meaning that you can use it anywhere by
the way if you drop by the web sandbox
you can see screw in action and hear
about how it was built or just visit
squish dot app if you're following along
on the live stream let me highlight a
couple of the key fields in here
the name start URL and icons members I
used to create the launcher shortcut for
the app and the display member tells the
browser how the app should be open when
it's run by specifying standalone this
requests an app window that's
independent of the browser
there are a few other display modes
available but standalone is the one
you'll likely want for your PWA to make
it a bit more real here's the launcher
icon in the Applications folder and in
the dock on a Mac after I've installed a
screw shop and then when I use one of
those to launch it it's gonna open that
start URL in its own app window this
theme color member provides the color
for the app title bar when it's launched
on both mobile and desktop
that's this orange bar at the top of the
window here and that's going to give
your app a distinctive on-brand
experience but don't worry if you omit
the theme color the browser is going to
choose a neutral color that fits into
the OS theme for you
and finally the scope determines the
extent of the app this is important for
accurate link capturing behavior where
the browser can intercept navigations
that fall within the scope of your app
and then redirect those links to open in
your app window I'll talk a little bit
more about link capturing on what we're
doing there later in the presentation
now we're continually adding new members
into the web app manifest to help define
new functionality but what's really
exciting is that as of 2018 last year
all major mobile browsers now respect
the web app manifest for their add to
homescreen functionality and we're
seeing an increasing number of desktop
browsers doing the same as well here
I've got a screen shot of duo hour video
calling PWA running in a standalone app
window on Chrome OS you can see they've
used a neutral theme color and the app
icon appears as the running app in the
Chrome OS shelf now let's move on to
Service Worker this is the secret source
for offline a lightweight network proxy
that intercepts Network requests and
provides cash resources should those
network requests fail this is the
technology that truly allows website
to break out of that online sandbox and
work seamlessly offline
technology that lets your website's
always be apps and not turn back into a
web browser tab when the network is down
the advent of serviceworker represents a
fundamental shift in how you should
think about architecting your web sites
and your web apps offline first rather
than online first we've seen time and
time again that building your app from
the ground up with offline in mind works
way better than trying to retrofit
offline functionality after the fact and
just like the web app manifest all major
browsers now ship full support for the
serviceworker api there is no reason for
modern web apps to not be built offline
first just like native apps using
service workers let's dive into what
that looks like I'm going to walk
through how you can use serviceworker to
provide a simple offline fallback page
in place of Chrome's offline page this
is an easy way to keep showing users
your themed app UI when the network
isn't available first we wait for the
page load event to register a
serviceworker and that's to make sure we
don't block the page load once
registration is complete the commands in
the serviceworker dot JS file are going
to be run you can specify an optional
scope for the serviceworker that denotes
the extent over which the serviceworker
has control the navigations that it's
going to be intercepted this should
definitely match the scope in the
corresponding web app manifest file to
ensure that the serviceworker controls
all of the URLs in your app so let's
move on to the serviceworker j/s file in
here we wait for the install event to
fire and note that this doesn't have
anything to do with installing your PWA
we're going to get to that in a moment
this just means that the serviceworker
is ready to go at this point we can
create an offline cache using the cache
API
you'll notice that I've versioned the
cash name so we can easily invalidate it
should the content become out-of-date so
once we have a cache open we just pass
it a list of the URLs we want cached and
then we'll the cache will go and fetch
those and store them ready for use later
the cache itself Maps keys of requests
to values of responses in this example I
only need to cache the one page because
the entirety of that page assets Styles
contents and scripts they're all
contained in that one HTML file in Lyon
and no other network requests will be
made whilst loading so now we've got
that page cached we need to ensure that
we retrieve and serve that page when the
network is down and we do that with a
fetch event listener which will be fired
for every Network request made by your
site this allows the service worker to
intercept all those Network requests and
substitute them if necessary
now I've emitted a couple of details in
this example that you'll want to look at
like patient validation and navigation
preload to ensure good performance so
when that fetch event fires we're going
to use a network first strategy in this
example we're going to respond to the
fetch event by calling the fetch method
and that sends the request to the
network should that network request fail
we'll catch the error open up our cache
and serve the offline page that we
stashed earlier ensuring that the user
is presented with app themed UI at all
times now this is an incredibly simple
example of offline support it is the
bare minimum that you can do we're not
even bothering to cache specific
resources just a single page to display
when the network is not available you
can and you should do a lot more and
many of our partners have done so
creating cache first loading strategies
where important content is always
available and important user journeys
are always accessible no matter the
network status buffering new navigations
for syncing with the server
later on now serviceworker is an
extremely low-level api you probably
want to avoid writing all of this
caching yourself if you can avoid it and
of course being the web there are plenty
of libraries to help you out one that we
really like is work box which wraps the
serviceworker api and protects you from
some of the dark corners and sharp edges
and it also means you can avoid having
to write your caching far by file and
instead use capsule routing paths here's
an example of how powerful and flexible
work box can be I'm using the routing
library to specify that CSS files should
be cached with a stale while revalidate
strategy that means that when we load a
CSS file we race the network and the
cache and whichever one gets back first
we send that response straight on
through the first time the network is
going to win because the cache is empty
but then that requests will be
transparently and immediately saved in
the case and from that point on it'll be
available offline you can find out more
about work box at work box jeaious org
it really makes developing powerful
offline capable web apps easy and paul
is going to show us one in action so
we've actually started to use these
pwace to ship some of our core apps in
Chrome OS and we use some of the goodies
that Tom mentioned this application uses
work box and web assembly so I recorded
a video of canvas this is our drawing
app to show you how it can work
completely offline so this drawing was
done by a colleague of mine
using this app when I was planning the
talk I asked around to see if we had any
cool illustrations that we could use I
was expecting something living up to my
high standard it's like a box or a
circle but this is what I got so this is
what we're gonna go with so in this
video first I turn off the Wi-Fi and you
can see you know that once I turn that
off there will be no more network
connectivity and then the artist uses
the stylus
Chrome OS tablet to sign his name and
the key thing here is he didn't know
anything about the offline status he
doesn't care whether it's connected or
not he just uses the app the same way
regardless and the serviceworker syncs
it up next time the device connects
thanks Paul
so once you've got a web app manifest
and an offline enabled experience
powered by service workers you can add
your own UI to prompt users to install
your PW a turning it from a website into
and install that we strongly recommend
taking advantage of this on desktop app
discovery still overwhelmingly runs
through search and download links
replacing those download links with a
PWA installation prompt allows for a
smooth seamless installation experience
and transition into an app window for
your users it means you're not relying
on users finding the browser's own
installation prompts installation is a
powerful operation since it gives your
site a permanent presence in the users
launcher so when your site loads in the
browser Chrome run some checks to
determine if you're eligible to prompt
for installation now your site needs to
be a PWA
so have a manifest have a serviceworker
with offline functionality and you'll
also need to have seen some user
engagement since installation prompting
shouldn't just happen the first time a
user visits your site when your site
passes those checks which could be run
dynamically through the lifecycle of the
current page load the before install
probe devan will be fired into your
top-level frame you'll need to add a
listener for this event on your window
object first up that event handler needs
to stash the event away somewhere that's
accessible later since you'll need to
call the prompt method on the event to
actually trigger installation putting
the method on the event ensures that the
user can't get an installation prompt
unless the browser has verified that the
site is eligible
before install prompt firing is your cue
that you can enable UI in your app to
ask the user to install for this simple
example
I'm just activating a disable
installation button when the event fires
but more broadly an installation prompt
usually works best if you have some UI
to tell the user what's going to happen
if they choose to install and we've got
a demo of what a good example of that
looks like coming up in just a moment
finally we wire up a click listener on
that now activated install button that
calls the prompt method on the stashed
event this is what triggers the browser
to show the installation prompt without
that click which signifies user intent
the prompt method is going to reject and
not show an installation prompt the
event also has a user choice promise
member that will resolve with the users
response to the prompt whether they
accepted installation or not another
useful event to listen to is the app
installed event which will be fired if
the app installation is triggered and
successful from any source now that
includes before install prompt but also
mechanisms that the browser might offer
such as with a three dot menu prompt so
you can see this come together in a few
mainstream apps I music Spotify on my
Chromebook here and you can see that
there's an install app link on the left
hand navigation when I click it you see
the familiar confirmation dialog and
then boom it's installed in my launcher
and in its own window
so this is this is you can see thank you
Spotify you can see this is this is how
you can actually integrate these before
install prompts events that Dom is
talking about to encourage your users to
install at the right time now one thing
that that was really is visible in that
earlier video but you'd have to really
be looking for it to see is this little
plus in the omnibox this is a feature
coming in early August with chrome 76
that we're super excited about this
means chrome will actually promote your
PWA
in its most prominent UI space in the
omnibox this uses the same trigger as
the before install prompt event but you
don't need to do any coding to get it
it's just intended to be subtle and
clear this website is also an app that
you can install so let's see how that
works in this video I'm installing the
PWA up duo which you saw earlier you can
see how it works with just a couple of
clicks and really no download time I
have an app in its own window and I can
use it to make a call so now that you've
seen the technology in action let's look
at how it can impact your users and your
business Hulu is a popular streaming
platform here in the US you can watch TV
and movies at home on your big screen or
on-the-go on your phone or laptop if you
were a Hulu user with a Windows machine
you could use their native app but their
native app had four user reviews and
poor usage and Hulu started thinking
about how to fix it they already had a
world-class web experience what did they
decide to do you guessed it they built
the PWA so here you can see the Hulu PWA
installed in Chrome OS on tablet mode it
looked good so they launched it within
three months
96% nearly all of their legacy app users
had switched to using this instead so
far so good
even better compared with the website
Hulu saw the users who installed the PWA
we're coming back to it more and they
were watching more videos a whole lot
more in fact it's still early in our
experience here with PW A's but this
does fit the pattern that we're seeing
because it's in the launcher it's easier
to remember and more natural to return
to this experience it's also an
immersive fullscreen experience so if
you're engaged in the activity you're
more likely to keep doing it so if you
have dedicated repeat users on your
website this same pattern might hold for
you thanks Paul just some amazing
numbers therefore for Hulu so it's
really impressive what the app like web
can do today cross-platform cross
browser from one code base now I was
talking to some folks around IO this
week and some of them were really
surprised to learn that the web could
already do a lot of these things access
camera and microphone API is use USB and
Bluetooth devices or run cross-compiled
performance critical code in webassembly
we've come such a long way
in the last decade but we're not
stopping here we know we've got a lot of
work to do to continue to expand the
capabilities of the web and further
improve our OS integration I'm super
excited to share some of our upcoming
roadmap all of which is being developed
out in the open in close collaboration
with partners developers and other
browsers we are hard at work on a native
file system API that will let the web
mediated by user consent directly read
and write to files on the user's disk
not a virtual file system but the real
file system and we know that this access
is one of the biggest remaining holes in
our integration story it's particularly
vital for porting existing creative
applications to the web and for enabling
web native creative applications like
Sketchup which we showed earlier to
become even more useful alongside
we're working on new web app manifest
declarations and api's that will let PWS
associate themselves with files and mime
types that means that when you
double-click a file it can open in an
installed PWA
this will further empower creative
applications that are shipped on the web
we're also working on new AP is for PW a
launch management right now we do some
basic link capturing on Android wear
URLs within the scope of your PW a will
open in your app now that works well
there because there's only ever one
instance of the app on Android and
changing state in response to a link is
expected behavior but on desktop that
doesn't quite make as much sense you
might want different behavior based on
the content of that link we're creating
a new launch event that will be fired
into a PW a as a service worker upon an
incoming navigation allowing you
fine-grained control to open new windows
focus existing windows or post message
the incoming data into an existing
window but that's not nearly all I
picked out several more of our top
priority API is that are currently under
development in Chrome of course the
dates up on the slide a tentative and
subject to slipping if we need more time
to get things exactly right but with
luck we're planning for all of these
api's to ship in chrome this year first
to origin trials for your feedback
before making it too stable
a few versions later those three api's
that I mentioned native file system PW a
file handling and launch event should
all make it to you by the end of the
year it's incredibly exciting how many
new capabilities we're bringing and we
really want to hear from you to make
sure that your needs are being met or
how we can do more to meet those
importantly with all of this new API
work we don't want to break the web and
Lou
the existing advantages of our platform
our universality our security and our
privacy guarantees we're working
carefully to close the functionality
gaps in the right way
collaborating with other browser vendors
and working out in the open to solicit
and act upon feedback from partners and
developers we're working incredibly
closely with security and privacy teams
to make sure we don't lose those
guarantees we've worked so hard to build
into the web platform to keep users in
control and aware of what is happening
our capabilities work is really pushing
the boundaries of the web adding much
much more native functionality but we're
focused on doing this in the right way
in a way that doesn't create
fragmentation or prevent other browsers
from following us PWA is Mary whet the
web with native experiences we want to
let you show off the best of the web
platform and build products that delight
users no matter where they are in the
world or what device they use empowering
the open web empowers you granting the
widest reach from a single codebase so
how can you get started you can make web
apps you can make them offline first
turn them into pwace leverage
installation and system integrations and
take advantage of the best of the web
and native worlds hopefully we've shown
you just how compelling progressive web
apps are as an Universal app platform
and how much more compelling they're
going to get over the next year so thank
you for coming to the talk
[Music]